كانت هذه الصواريخ البالستيه حتى الامس
القريب عامله ردع سفياتي امام تهديدات
بحرب كادت تندلع بين المعسكريين الغربي
والشرقي
تختلف اليوم الظروف والسياقات في خضم حرب
مستعره في اوكرانيا
وهددته وما تزال
بوقوع اصطدام النووي
لم يكن اكثر الخبراء درايه بسياسه
الخارجيه لروسيا يتوقعوا قبل النحو عام من
الان ان تشون موسكو ما تطلق عليها عمليه
عسكريه في اوكرانيا
نفسه ستها مرارا والى حد السخريه احيانا
نيتهم اجتياح الجاره الغربيه جغرافيا
والمتزايد ميلها نحو الغربي ايديولوجيا
وسياسيا وعسكريا بعد يومين من اعترافه
باستقلال جمهوريتين
عن اوكرانيا
فجر الرابع والعشرين من فبراير شباط عمليه
عسكريه لتحقيق اهداف من بينها نزع سلاح
اوكرانيا
طلبت فيها بالحصول على ضمانه نمليه من
بينها تعهد بعدم انضمام كيف الى حلف
النيته
مقترحات ووجهت بالرفض وهو من بين ما بررت
به موسكو حينئذ لجوءها الى القوه منذ
اليوم الاول لتدخل العسكري تارجح اداء
الجيش الروسي والفصائل المواليه له بين
التقدم الكاسح تاره وتراجع الموجع اثاره
اخرى وهو مارجعتهم موسكو لاسباب من بينها
تزايد الدعم الغربي لكيف والحاجه الى
تعزيز عدد القوات وهو مدفع بوتين لاعلان
عمليه تعبئه جزئيه شملت 300,000 شخص
واظهرت عيوب تنظيميه كثيره وكان من
تداعيتها فرار عشرات الالاف الى خارج
البلاد هربا من التعب
ضد روسيا تم تسريحه القوات الاوكرانيه
وتدريبها وهذا ما لم نقيمه بشكل صحيح
بصراحه
القياده العسكريه اليوم تواصلت الى
استنتاجات ومع التعبئه الجزئيه ستتغير
الامور لمصلحه قريبا العقوبه اكثر سلاحا
استخدمه الغرب ضد موسكو منذ ان اطلقت
عمليتها العسكريه
ادفرض عليها اكثر من ثمانيه الاف 1500
اجراء من خلال المؤشرات الاقتصاديه يبدو
ان موسكو استطاعته الى حد معين احتواء
الصدمه والتعايش مع طبيعتها
الاقتصاد الروسي والمجتمع تعايش بسرعه مع
الواقع الجديد لكن هذا لا يخفي وجود مشاكل
من بينها مغادره عدد كبير من المواطنين
الى الخارج لاسباب مختلفه تفرض على روسيا
الان الحزمه التاسعه من العقوبات لكنها
سيكون اضعف نتيجه تكيف في الاقتصاد مع
القيود ضمه روسيا نهايه سبتمبر ايلول
اربعه مقاطعه وهي دنيا
اثار الجدل ولم يحظ باعتراف دولي خطوه
سياسيه فارقه في الصراع رغم انها لم تؤثر
على الوضع الميداني المتارجح بين التصعيد
وضع يتوقف المنح الذي سيسلكه العام المقبل
في راي كثيرين على حسابات كل طرف وان غابت
اي بوادر لتسويه الصراع في المستقبل
المنظور على الاقل